[Musique]
en france ce sont donc les listes europe
écologie qui ont créé la grosse surprise
du scrutin plus de 16% c'est le meilleur
score de l'histoire des verts de daniel
cohn bendit qui ont devancé les
socialistes dans de nombreuses grandes
villes les écologistes vont ils devenir
durablement une grande force politique
dans notre pays en tout cas les
militants et les sympathisants ont fêté
ces résultats inespérés une bonne partie
de la nuit isabelle sabouraud
encore un peu groggy par ce score
inespéré les verts d'europe écologie se
sont remis au travail sans perdre de
temps pas de triomphalisme juste le
plaisir d'aligner côte à côte ce qui ont
fait le succès de ces élections une
alliance qui assure rassembler au delà
de l'électorat vert traditionnel je
ressens ce que j'ai ressenti cette nuit
on a fait une bonne campagne
béchir aujourd'hui au vu des
informations que 90 14 et 15 députés
européens on double le nombre débuté par
rapport à la législature précédente et
c'est vrai que ça veut dire que le
groupe verts au parlement européen va
être encore plus important que ce qui
n'était donc va pouvoir peser de manière
centrale dans les débats ils ont fait la
fête tard dans la nuit les militants et
les têtes de liste après trente ans de
travail on est entré distille dans l'âge
de la crédibilité militant de la
première heure aux jeunes générations
tous ont savouré ce score auquel
personne n'aurait osé croire il ya
encore quelques semaines
car
c'est historique avoir un tel
pourcentage avoir autant d'électeurs
c'est vraiment la récompense d'une très
belle campagne je crois on sait jamais
laisser divertir sur les problèmes
franco français on a fait un vrai une
vraie campagne européenne a fait une
campagne de terrain un gros soulagement
c'est une grande victoire on est super
heureux on l'espérait le on n'y croyait
plus timidement moi c'est tout un
discours que j'entends depuis tout petit
ma mère ait investi dans ce genre d'aidé
depuis les années 70 on se moque
énormément des écolos et là vraiment il
ya un parcours et nantes a été
parcourue est vraiment
contre toute attente l'alliance autour
de daniel cohn bendit a fonctionné et
fait jeu égal avec le parti socialiste
le dimanche 7 juin 2009 restera gravée
pour tous comme le d-day de l'écologie
le jour où tout commence
[Musique]